tonight mickey moniak was out in the
outfield taking some fly balls getting
himself used to the cutouts because he's
out there tonight making his first major
league start it's game three between the
bills of the mets it's down to 12 games
for the fills they find themselves right
now at 524-24
aaron nola in his start i was talking
about him september 6th against the mets
let's see
if he's got a better curveball tonight
because he did not have a good curveball
he threw more changeups and he got beat
on a change up remember that great two
out hit by jimenez
so one out conforto moves up to second
davis at first and dom smith coming up
and dom lines one at the left center for
a base in conforto to third he's going
to be waved home on the third goes davis
dom trying for two he slides in safely
with a double and an rbi and the mets
have struck first it's one nothing new
york rbi number 39 double number 18 for
dom smith now second and third and one
out for canoe
and robbie lines one that's into right
field for a base hit in the score comes
davis smith going to try to score
harpers throws skips on by backed up
nicely by nola but two runs score on the
base hit for canoe and the mets have an
early three-nothing lead
they take on seth lugo for the second
time as a starter this year 91 in his
last start so now seth lugo is ready to
go and a struggle for bryce he's over
his last 11.
out to center field that is well hit
nimmo's going back toward the 409 side
and it is gone
into the bushes
bryce hopper is ninth home run of the
year phillies are on the board it's now
a 3-1 game now alec bowm is the hitter
opposite way that's well hit conforto
going back it is gone back to back home
runs for the phillies harper 4 33 to
center
alec balm
hits one deep to right
time with two good if two's good three's
better
that one's hit well out to right field
conforto turns it's gone
back to back to back three is better and
the phillies tie it up here at the
bottom of the first inning
two outs and here's hazley
pulled to the right side of me sent it
to right field the phillies will take
the lead
segora scores rbi single for hasley
four runs in in the inning
brings
to the plate
turn ball wave down
knapp will flip it to first strikeout is
recorded
two three on the put out and that is the
first strikeout of the night for aaron
nola here's the o2 pitch
and a fastball call strike three or just
do that yeah i think everybody knew it
including the batter
back-to-back strikeouts for nola pretty
good way to bounce back and there are
two men away bryce harper who started
the home run barrage will be next
in the air to right field wow forget
about that one that is a long home run
off the facing of the upper deck
[Applause]
445 feet his second home run of the game
the phillies lead it 5-3
and now segura coming up
ground ball toward the left side it's a
base hit it to left-center field ball
will score gregorius to third
rbi single for segora he's two for two
and the phillies add another one it's
6-3 here in the second
obviously a big at bat right here
one-two coming
and he got him with the breaking ball
step on the plate for the force and that
ends the inning
so rosmah ramirez a lifesaver again two
and a third scoreless in relief there's
conforto's walked and struck out
swag and a miss he had a way out in
front
strikeout number five for nola
all right so now he's got one out with
jd davis up
and a call strike three on the outside
corner davis is down looking
six strikeouts for aaron
robinson canelo will lead it off here in
the sixth inning
swag gonna miss
got him over the top of the curve ball
seven strikeouts for nola
alonso grounded into a double play to
win the top of the first then popped to
second in the fourth
curve ball hits a deep left field back
goes moniak looking up and it's out of
here pete alonzo loses one on a curve
ball from nola his 12th home run of the
year and that gets the mets a little
closer it's now six to four good that's
left to nimo with two out and two on
and nimo strokes one on the right center
field for a base hit around third and
scoring as mcneal as it rolls to the
wall here comes jimenez around third
he's heading home he will score nimmo to
third he slides in with a two-run triple
and the mets have tied the game at six
brandon nemo's in a big series
with both teams and nimbo drives one
deep right field forget it that ball is
way out of here into the second deck
nimmo gives the mates the lead in the
ninth inning
so now the wilson whisperer dom smith
dom hits one out to center field chasing
hazley back to the track at the wall
it's off the wall and bouncing away from
him harper has to come over to help out
conforto around third he will score dom
heads to third he's in standing with an
rbi triple and the mets now lead it
eight to six
bobby know had a two run single back in
the first inning
he hits it in the air to deep right
field forget that that is long gone
robbie cannot adds a two-run homer and
the mitts have scored four runs in the
ninth inning canoe's eighth home run of
the year and it's 10-6 new york bases
are loaded and the phillies will get the
tying run to bat
mccutchen hits the ground ball rosario's
got it gets the force and the ball game
is over